last night I had a dream and about who
first met
[Applause]
we were criminals
friends
and then we became Guardians
this is the end of the road let's make
it count
on Fifth
I will destroy the Guardians It's Time
to Say Goodbye
Summer begins it's a Face-Off
with their final tour I guess we'll die
trying
I know who you are already accordions of
the Galaxy Vol 3. are you ready
I was eight years old when I left there
you want me to drive no I'll drive
figure out how to put it in backwards
in theaters May Fair 3D PG-13 tickets
until now the Guardians of the Galaxy
have no place in my world kiss your mom
with that face oh no
sound corners of the universe consider
him God
face off
well I guess we'll die trying
I decided I try and ain't our thing no
more
a Galaxy volume three tickets now